This question is really just asking us to use our common sense. Does is make
sense that Grant will make money if he doesn't sell any products? I would argue
no. If no one buys his products, he won't get any money back. And since he put
money into making them, he'll be at a loss. And fortunately we have a positive
y-intercept, not a negative one. So, this means this is positive profit. So, the
information from our equation is not really in line with what we would think
logically would happen. So, I would say that the two points that Grant gave us
to start out, which you may remember were 60, 1000. And 100, 1200 were probably
off. We based our entire equations just off the info we got from these two
points to help us figure out our slope, and our y-intercept. So, this just goes
to show you that if your initial data is wrong, your final conclusion will
probably not make very much sense. I think this is also testament to the
importance of being able to connect math with real world situations. And why we
have to keep ourselves grounded in what our variables mean when we're solving
problems.